I've noticed that you when I talk to you
you either make no eye contact with me
or too much damn it you look you'll be
talking to me but looking straight
across the room that way at this wall
that says SiriusXM or
you'll be riveted to me and your eyes
don't blink at all yeah like a reptile
so what's the story with that do you
have a prep you you have a I love you
looking away it's really yeah because
it's not looking away for the rest of
the interview
get used to it buddy here it comes
seriously you just uh yeah I've never
seen that technique before Tim I've been
wanting to tell you something for quite
a long time now and I'm looking
completely yeah at you I I was looking
for the door I could tell
you wanted out listen
just you got questions yeah I do but
whenever I start you cut me off I don't
think that's true with let's check the
tape so far Adam has there been some
cutting off to be fair it's been a
little cutting off okay a little bit
perfect but you heard that one point
where that I it's like okay I'm not
going to cut him off and it went on
forever
so you started shaving during one of my
anecdotes which I thought was incredibly
rude I didn't and you brought all the
props it was very impressive all right
let's switch this tone let's get to know
let's get to know people okay ready go
I'm gonna ask I'm gonna get to know you
okay and then um your follow-up
questions
yeah you can cut me off with your
follow-up questions I want to First say
that I think you're a terrific actor now
we I've talked to you before uh about
acting and sometimes I call you up with
questions about acting yeah because I
think you're very smart about acting and
I asked I like to ask you in that movie
did you like them what did you think
about what that person was doing and you
always break it down and you have a very
good smart intuitive analysis of what
that person's doing
I don't know how to do any of that this
may shock you but I am not an actor I
don't have an actor's soul I don't even
understand how it works I'm not I
couldn't be in a scene with you could
you imagine if you had to do a scene
with me in a movie see what happens when
I don't cut them off
I actually wish you cut them off a
little earlier
when
I said you were a terrific actor you did
you started with a compliment but then
you went on about your thing yeah what
are you worried about
first of all you're a comic genius no
let's not get crazy listen if you want
to ask okay you're a comic genius sure
and you've been a comic genius
for like 60 years now okay now it's
getting crazy I once uh we went on a
road trip together we did I don't know
if you called a road but it's a pretty
lengthy drive and I heard all about your
beginnings and uh it's really quite
phenomenal are you writing a book are
you oh you listened to I thought you and
I went on a road trip and you heard
about my beginnings
yeah we drove up the coast you and I had
a romantic getaway let's just call it
what it was I know I thought it was the
first it was gonna be the first of many
I thought we were going to be the male
Felman Louise
um which when you think about it is a
stupid idea well you put up the red hair
that's true
I'm wait I'm Gina Davis wouldn't you be
Susan Sarandon with the hair it wasn't
kind of reddish yeah but Gina Davis was
taller
I think it would be Gene and Davis I
mean listen again the listeners are
going to decide but I think it's right
Gina Davis all right yeah you be Gina
Davis yeah I I agree with you yeah nice
scene with Brad Pitt yeah
I gave him a start right
him with you and him with the hair dryer
okay you remember that I do it's a good
scene
um again there you are with your good
acting mind breaking down a scene I
don't know how you do it and
I'm sorry I cut you off but is there a
question
I'm being serious why does this have to
be a question I don't know what these
things are there's the one that's you
and me it's not like any other podcast
yes usually I have questions okay
there's kind of a flow to it
what you and I have and what the fans
expect is something frustrating
um
that starts and stops uh that takes wild
uh turns
um that maybe ends up being less than
some of its parts that's what they want
from us I'm just worried about the ones
that like if my wife were who are
listening right now it she would have
she would have turned it off by now well
first of all she does that when we go to
dinner she's like she often reaches over
and tries to turn a a volume button on
my head that isn't there yeah she's I've
seen her try to change the channel on me
when the when the four of us are out to
dinner
and my wife is right along with her on
that one it's true isn't it
they're like you guys ago okay I'm gonna
ask you a question yep our lives are
very different my work has always been
you stay in this one place and you do
this and you don't move here's your talk
show desk don't you move your
life which I've always kind of envied is
like you said there's this gig in Wales
and suddenly you're living in Wales for
a couple of months I've always been
fascinated by that does that get old or
do you still love it I I always wanted
to have a talk show
I just wanted and I still to this day
it's like one of those body switch
movies full fantasy about just like
having a talk show I read about
someone's giving up their talk show and
I think to myself
you know should I raise my hand what's
the deal I feel like I could I'd love
that regularly would you like that well
I think the answer is yes
yeah I love a I love routine
I do love routine I'm being serious yeah
you know my day
you know like every you know I like the
routine of it
I like um
what is it that I like about it I don't
know but I always thought it'd be
really cool uh to have a talk show to
have a talk show yeah what about the day
in and day out over and over again could
you do that wouldn't you miss I'm going
to Japan now
you know and it doesn't need to be in a
a robot no I mean uh I mean for years I
I no I don't think I would I think I I
think I'd enjoy it
I enjoy talking to people I'm you know I
mean even though that we're not well
we're starting to have an actual
conversation here but I do I tricked you
into it you see what I did I did you
lulled me yeah there was some stuff at
the beginning but that's our process and
then we get to this but you know what
you are you're uh always been a
hilarious talk show guest
um again people when they talk to me
about appearances that people have made
Uh Kevin Newman's name comes up
and obviously Norm MacDonald's name
comes up and he's definitely comes over
and your name pops up a lot people liked
you
doing panel they liked you because you
come at things from a very different
angle you know you've got a very quirky
dry sense of humor very funny and people
enjoy it I appreciate I never thought do
I have a dry sense of humor I think you
do well you have a dry delivery you have
a dry delivery oh you have a very dry
delivery because I feel like and I'm
just like a puppy dog
you know like I'm like one of those loud
do you think of that I mean no no who
thinks of you as a loud you're not a
loud guy
like kids
well you're always angry around your
kids I've noticed that yeah there's a
lot of God damn it God damn it and then
you know Alexis is like Tim Tim take it
easy you say you quiet woman and you do
a lot of that right and
um there's a lot of who touched my drink
and
I need more to drink so there's that and
when the when the one food uh is
touching the other food oh these Foods
can't touch right when the eggs are
touching the toast and I just lose it
you know what's crazy do you ever watch
uh remember the movie um Sleeping with
the Enemy Julia Roberts where she's with
the crazy type A husband uh and he needs
everything to be just perfect or he
flies into a rage sadly I missed it okay
it's many many years ago I'm a fan of uh
just the other day watched um Aaron
Brockovich which is a much better movie
I'm guessing than the one you're talking
about yeah the one I'm talking about is
the one that everyone came to see
because it was oh God again
I'm shamed every time I speak on Conan
O'Brien's podcast
by Tim all offense ridiculous it's
called Conan needs a friend
needs is the operative word exactly yeah
I need help here that's where I never
needed you more so I'm trying to and
I've been trying to actually talk to you
I've been trying to talk to you and hang
out for like six months and the only way
to do it was to book you on the podcast
wow what kind of friendship is that
suddenly we're together because I booked
you on the podcast first of all a true
buddy would have been like where are you
you know like you know you have you're
like oh I'm coming
I was in New Orleans for two months you
could have said oh my god let's go visit
Oliphant in New Orleans we'll go hit
Jazz Fest we'll cruise around I can't
take Jazz Fest you know what we've been
amazing
scale first of all here's the thing of
jazz fest everybody they go people go
and there's large groups and and in
order to find people in the crowd people
have flags and stuff so they're like
that's our group but with you we could
have just been like where's Conan we
could just see you right we're like
there's that red inflatable thing
outside of a car uh car lot right we're
just looking flapping around we're just
looking for yeah like a really
unattractive Gina Davis okay you know
what where is she I didn't come here
where is she to be called an
unattractive Gene today you could have
flown out here's the main point I'm not
that kind of guy I'm not that kind of
guy I'm not that kind of guy I'm not the
kind of guy who says it's time for me to
hit the Big Easy and hang with Oliphant
at the Jazz Fest yeah that's the
opposite of who I am no I can't do that
I was working what kind of jazz are they
playing
is it that kind of thing I think there
is a tent for that
is that happening because I can't do
that and then someone's give a third
example because I think people want it
it's amazing you don't know how much I
could just see you in Star Wars on that
last one
you could have been in the bar right and
there could have been a little uh yeah
subtitles underneath me saying I'll give
you 40 Greek guards for the glove glove
right yeah damn